I want to say again congratulations on
thank you how is your older daughter
adjusting to life as a big sister you
know she's an amazing big sister but I
know that it's been a little hard for
her but just because she was like you
know she was everything and she still is
and so and I wanted and then that so we
did I've found ways to kinda like - two
days ago we went and did like a little
hotel stayin at chocolate cake in bed
marched Aladdin doing like you know I
want it like there I'm definitely like
want her to know she's still she's my
number one Hey I love you you're so cool
I really love the day I got I love you
so much I just love you you're the best
that I've ever had do you see yourself
expanding the family larger than that
I'm not planning on it okay better like
really but if you know a kid came into
the world I definitely would not I got a
couple wouldn't be a mistake you want it
you want my I gotta take one of your
idea at least one who knows are there
any new songs on the album dedicated to
your girl oh man I will say that there
are a couple songs on this record that
are love songs and I typically I do not
write love songs but I think that having
all these girls in the house with me was
has softened my heart a little bit and
kind of led me to higher grounds I was
like me before the Thunder
new album is coming is called evolve
explain the title to me this record for
us is is an evolution of a lot of ways a
lot of different things I think
lyrically for me this record was written
from a really healthy spot we came home
for tour we've been home for like a year
and so yeah I think that hopefully that
shows in the record any collaborations
on the kaabah no I think you know we I
know we live in kind of the world of
collaborations right now but you know we
we really are focused on the band still
and we feel like we're still kind of
beginning to find out who we are as a
band and we still feel young in a lot of
ways and so we went into this record and
we talked about it and we decided now we
just wanted to do it all myself I'm
tired of the way the things been Oh
I think the best concerts are the ones
where you feel sort of close to the
personas even if you're up in the
nosebleeds you have that connection you
feel close to the performance close to
the to the artists so we're going to try
and capture that even a little more on
this album and many people feel like
it's just one big